a woman is suing singer/songwriter R
Kelly for allegedly failing to disclose
a sexually transmitted disease
she also accuses him of sexual battery
Kelly is one of the most successful R&B
singers of all time his multiple
chart-topping hits include bump and
grind and I believe I can fly and he's
no stranger to controversy after a
series of sexual misconduct allegations
by former girlfriend's several music
streaming services including Spotify and
Apple removed Kelly songs from their
featured playlist a growing protest
movement online is called mute our Kelly
trigger Duncan spoke to the 20 year old
who is suing Kelly Jericka good morning
good morning you know this woman faith
Roger says that she was in a
relationship with our Kelly when she was
19 for nearly a year before leaving
during that time she says Kelly
instructed her to call him daddy
and would lock her up for hours at a
time Roger says he even introduced her
to one of the five women Kelly allegedly
said he was raising he was like here's
my number
take it text me a picture of you so I
know it's you with your name 20 year old
faith Roger says in March of last year
she met r Kelly in San Antonio at a
party after his concert he was older
than me and that was a red flag you know
did you look at him as a 50 year old man
at the time not at all even being around
him he doesn't act his age and you feel
like I'm chilling with somebody I went
to high school with
[Music]
after two months of phone calls texting
and facetiming she says our Kelly flew
her to New York to attend one of his
shows and even paid for her hotel the
morning after the performance
she says Kelly visited her room he turns
on all the lights and he's like take off
your clothes and he says that you know
with authority in his voice not just you
know he's demanding me to do this and I
didn't take off my clothes because why
would I just wasn't ready sex isn't
something you know I'm ready for it
according to Roger she ultimately
submitted to having sex and alleges
Kelly recorded it on his iPad without
her consent did you want to have sex
with him no he has this type of like
intimidation right off the back you know
so I was just waiting for it to be over
what happens after that what sort of
conversation did you guys have he comes
over and he starts like rubbing the side
of my face and he asked me how old I was
and I told him and he's like you know if
you're really you know 16 that you can
tell daddy right and he was like you
know you just look about 14 15 or 16
Rogers who was 19 at the time is suing
are Kelly for sexual battery
and willfully deliberately and
maliciously infecting her with herpes
and she claims Kelly mentally sexually
and verbally abused her
she believes that now 51 year old Kelly
pursues teenage or underage girls and
lures them into engaging in sex acts in
April she filed a criminal complaint
with the Dallas Police Department and
says under their advisement she recorded
a phone call with Kelly hoping he would
admit to knowingly giving her an STD I
don't know about you and I don't never
know about nothing
Rodgers claims Kelly also routinely
locked her in a van the first time I was
left in the car for a total of eight
hours that night and the child lock was
on the car
Rodgers believes Kelly was priming her
to join a group of women she says he
lives and travels with he goes on to
tell me that he raises five women some
of them have been with him for 15 years
and he basically was trying to make it
seem like it was a family thing
he described these women as being his
family then he goes on to tell me you
know what I love you because you remind
me of them she claims she had a brief
conversation with at least one of those
women Joycelyn Savage
my dog is severely brainwashed in July
of 2017 savages parents held a news
conference asking authorities to remove
their daughter from Kelly's home we just
want him to release her and let her go
over for life they believe savage and
several other girls were being
controlled by Kelly and forced to
perform sex acts as part of a cult but
savage denied those claims to TMZ I'm in
a happy place with my life and I'm not
being brainwashed for decades there have
been questions concerning our Kelly and
his relationship with underage girls in
2008 he was acquitted on child
pornography charges prosecutors alleged
he made a sex tape with a girl around 14
years old
a 2017 BuzzFeed investigation describes
three women who say they were sexually
abused by Kelly and were part of a sex
cult Kelly has long denied these
allegations a social media campaign to
mute our Kelly led to promoters
cancelling a concert in Kelly's hometown
of Chicago last month he reacted on
Twitter never heard of a show being
canceled because of homeless
don't put that on me despite nationwide
protests at shows
the three-time Grammy winner is still
performing as for Rogers she hopes by
coming forward she can help put an end
to Kelly's long history of alleged abuse
what was it about him that kept you
going back um it's not like all the time
he was just you know this devious person
there's been times where he's you know
crying and he's telling me you know
about his children about his ex-wife
comparing himself to Michael Jackson and
how you know how how the media destroyed
him and he felt like that's what was
going on in his life why I filed a
lawsuit I wanted for girls like me who
are gonna run into him in the future and
he's gonna do the exact same thing but
it could get worse you know I chose to
walk away what about the ones who don't
walk away we reached out to our Kellie's
representatives and they told us they
have no comment on Rogers as allegations
or the new lawsuit in a Washington Post
article in April of Representative for
Kelly said the singer categorically
denies all claims and allegations
Rodgers says she is not looking for a
settlement and her lawyers say they will
be seeking a jury trial you know this I
think is just so surprising for people
who've been following his career and and
everything surrounding these allegations
for years to hear that this girl was 19
at the time our Kelly was 50 yeah you
know as you point out these are not new
allegations about him it's been these
stories about him have been going on for
years starting with the marriage to alia
when she was 15 and of course she's no
longer with us but maybe in this time
that we're living in now Jericka maybe
people were here differently and pay
attention to it in a way that they never
have because it's very creepy and
disturbing well and also particularly
with a sexually transmitted disease this
goes to trial discovery they will talk
to his doctors that should be knowable I
didn't know that's against the law it's
against the law to knowingly give
somebody I mean this is an STD she's
gonna live with her the rest of her life
yeah very very disturbing story thank
you but I'm glad she's speaking up and
I'm glad you're telling the story